you are a proud Australian you're very
proud of coming from Australia well yeah
I am proud of him
oh man I'm a terribly embarrassed
Australian we had a thing going I'm
sorry guys um no I I am no I'm not I'm
really not patriotic at all my parents
are both immigrants I have no connection
to the homeland except when it comes to
you know emojis there's there's all of
them not all of the the country slides
but there are a lot of flags and then
right next to the flag says this huge
blank space and no Australian flag have
you guys ain't gonna drop did you we
have this there's a lot of Australian so
there's no Australian flag emoji what do
they have against Australians like look
at that place how hard would it be for
them to make an Australian flag emoji I
don't know the answer to that because I
don't work for Apple or the emoji
company but I don't think it'll be that
hard yeah there's also there's also
while I'm on the topic of it there's
also a lot of white people emojis yeah
have you noticed it I've been thinking
about other things but it really doesn't
racial imbalance shows such an imbalance
actually I brought another screenshot
cuz I just you're wrong look at all of
those white people who yeah it is all
white people have their are their stage
of life it's just yet are there absent
two adult yet that's it that's the total
is there any diversity at all oh yeah no
no I should yet there are hey I bought
another Ok Go screams you doesn't fix it
[Applause]
before
you